What
should Aizu do?
This assassination magic is a space weapon developed by Marukuni in her previous life. It
's prototype is God's staff.
Drops metal from satellite orbit
Mass weapons comparable to each, but
carries a large mass to satellite orbit.
There are problems with aerodynamic heating during post or re-entry, etc.
It hasn't been realized yet.
It's easy for me now.
Then, I
completed it as a gravity reversal magic with a formula, and
now I can't carry it to the orbit of the stars.I
cast wind magic on the tungsten spear that reached the Heisei orbit,
give it a month of aerodynamics, and let it fall freely.
It's aiming.
We need advanced and precise calculations and execution to plan a direct hit.For
that reason, I
trained on the uninhabited island that Maa found for me.
is released in an instant The
lineage has ended since the time Dangu Sten threw the spear panew